whose August with her so August Wilson
wrote the play - he's only written one
other thing okay
loser no no IMDB credits
hello reject those Gregory Alba here
Jason Horton here Jason Horton famous
sketch comedian on the YouTube market
fences official trailer number one
starring George Denzel Washington here
we go guys
Denzel is people kind of like him yeah
cuz perfect symmetry I heard these faces
performance it's why so good-looking
kinda like a Taylor Lautner over people
you know that's what people call them
Hollywood let's see I bet this is gonna
be some like Oscar [ __ ] feel it feel it
just from the thumbnail I so I think
Viola Davis or someone yeah not buy up I
forgot it's fine paramount painting and
no monetization ask you a question how
come you never liked me like you what
law is there say I got to like you know
alright don't you eat every day
answer me when I talk to you don't you
eat every day yeah as long as you in my
house you put a sale on the end of it
when you talk to me they said you eat
every day they still got a roof over
your head yes I got clothes on your back
yes sir why do you think that is cuz he
hell I know it's cuz of me but why do
you think that is cuz you like me thank
you I go out of here every morning I
bust my butt
cuz I like you're about the biggest fool
ever saw a man is supposed to take care
of his family
you live in my house forget belly with
my food put your behind on my bed
because you're my son this is my duty to
take care of you I hope on sibility to
you I ain't got to like you now I'll
give you everything I've got to give you
I'll give you your life me and your mom
won't work that out between us unlike in
your black ass wasn't wanted a bargain
now don't you go through life worrying
about whether somebody like you or not
you must be making sure that they're
doing right by you you understand what
I'm saying
everything that boy do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years and with you
I gave 18 years of my life to stand in
the same spot as you
directed by Denzel huh Wow wasn't very
funny for a comedy I wasn't yeah I was
expecting a lot more laughter yeah fart
joke or something but dad son relations
probably get bought in the end yeah yeah
I think this is based on a Pulitzer
Prize winning play yeah recording at the
trailer yeah with Viola Davis's yeah
those were some real [ __ ] tears
that's like snot and everything yeah oh
it's an unattractive cry right there
yeah but if she was crying yelling at me
like that I VI probably pissed my pants
yeah it's a really good trailer because
it starts off and then it really ramps
up with like sounds yo yeah which really
kind of is unnerving it seems like the
tone and style is really in tune with
the characters dark feelings you know
what solve all these problems you know
the Sun wouldn't be ask him if he had an
iPhone the iPhone saved the day iPhone
save the day you just be invested in his
phone oh yeah that would've changed
YouTube videos this kind of reminds me
of Denzel Washington's character and
training they lived mm-hmm and became a
dad turn up into yeah I mean it looks
like another great role my denzel like
he is so consistent yeah it is work I
like how he's been having a nice balance
of like entertaining like action films
yeah with a drama as well like he had
like flight and equalizer not
magnificent seven now this may be
another equalizer I think yeah an
equalizer too as well it's a great
balance this character though a
father-son stories get to me a lot yeah
I need anything to do what parents will
really like cause me to really cry no
I'm gonna cry when I watch this really
relatable yeah but in some way yeah I
don't know somebody once he didn't have
a dad girl yeah let's not make fun of
you yeah let's not do that
we'll wait till the cameras off then
we'll do that
I'm interested to know this is this new
guy is this - son yeah I didn't see the
what was he direct dental director that
one movie with Forest Whitaker was a cup
of good debate or something like that
III know he directed it and it got
pretty good reviews I get more inclined
to see a second film instead because I'm
like okay you gotta get his feet wet
with the first run now we can see how he
really tests skills is it the framing of
every shot here looks awesome the whole
cinematography looks great it was very
authentic it looks very authentic it
really seems like it's defining a
specific time what I love about just
from seeing denzel's perform it's like
he does with all his characters as he
brings so much layers to it cuz it's not
like he's just a serious uptight dad
yeah like you can tell like as much as
he's being hard on his son you're like
you love him though yeah there's a party
that was you know yeah and it's like a
different era - obviously I don't know
specifically what time and I like seeing
movies like that where the society
reflects the way how parents raised
their kids back then cuz politically
correct wasn't at the top of them
no no nowadays I mean so many people now
or like you people go to therapy and
they really deal with their emotional
wounds and everything like that and
parents go to therapy now - and this was
not the time where old parent would go
to therapy and really deal with their
emotional stuff seeing this like
contrast here of like how dad's used to
teach your kids how to be men yeah
bottle up you work hard you just keep
going yeah and it's like you know you'll
get love can be weak sometimes this is
you know it's you have to like leave
with anger and aggression sometimes I'm
sure probably gives you some skills you
might survival skills you might need
yeah yeah like that's what I mean like
men would you just survive oh yeah
that's a god you have to survive in this
world and now we just cry and now that
matters just so emotional all the time
I'm a crier and I really want to see
Viola Davis and Denzel working together
that's gonna be a really that's gonna
really exciting to see that just those
two going back and forth as we both know
how great both of those guys are
wondering how much time this is gonna
span I'm not familiar with the play
never heard of it before
I mean it looks like everyone is
somewhat of the same aged well that
leaves out throughout the trailers I
don't know like I show him like he's
playing football I don't know if it's
just like
high school years he gets into college
or whatever I am interested to see what
the what the character growth of this
would be because last thing I would want
to start to have a cheesy in I would
like to cry by the end of this film yeah
I'm telling you that right now I would
like to be very moving denzel's gonna
have to dive in dance I asked the guy
yesterday he has to dive hang himself
while jerking off just like someone
would Wikipedia the story and I like
that's how fences always on the edge
yeah it's yeah that's cool clever clever
I probably like to read the actual play
before watching this but you want no I
will you'll see it'll arc your words the
reaction to me reading it yeah Viola
Davis is tears though man you see him
backing down yeah yeah when he when she
claps back as they say he's just like oh
I'm scared of women what you should be
and what's cool is that I like it this
is based on play cuz Denzel is a play
actor and and he's one of those actors
who I think I've heard him say this to
of her many actors who come from plays
say this about film even though they
become big film stars they'll say like
film is not real acting it's usually
plays where the real acting is at
because in play it's like you got start
gonna be getting to the end no come no
cuts no retakes no paint aware of all
this other [ __ ] yeah yeah there's no
editing involved its readjust a raw
performance so I wouldn't be surprised
if he did this as a play first and then
he wanted to adapt it into a movie so
it's gonna be really cool to see how
because it's he seems like he is like an
actor's director yeah I'm actually
really intrigued by this yeah this looks
like it's gonna be okay heartbreak yeah
this looks like a great Christmas film
yeah I love a good character study kind
of film and I think when you get great
actors and a great character study kind
of film you're gonna have one hell of
like yeah this is like total Oscar kind
of but what I love about it it doesn't
feel like Oscar bait no you know you
like you know when you get like an Oscar
bait trailer yeah now this one I think
they just kind of slipped in here yeah
just like here's this movie because this
looks dark and edgy and pushing pushing
lines of like family relationships yeah
this is this looks like it give me
something different and something that
could be really riveting to watch
I met someone in Zurich
who said that Denzel is impossible and
you what I want to hear that I want to
hear that either yeah but you know what
they heard someone say it it must be
true like he does Ellie can I sleep over
tonight he's like now that's weird he's
like no you're an [ __ ] so they make
dent Denzel made people cry on set oh
really
I can see that happening yeah he's
really intimidating yeah but you know it
brings out the best work then like win
it whatever man as long as you get great
films yeah like deja vu I'm okay with
that I'm okay with that
man on fire mm-hmm I'm talking about
denzel's greatest films right here most
of you lie when he was like he was in
jail but he is the one where he was in
like any of them use in jail for doing
sparking no not that I
nothing her out of time is it that one
there's some day yeah he's in jail we
kept sneaking out weird he kept
disappearing or so things started
happening oh man I can't think of it I
think it was him that was in it
fallen virtuosity yeah I'm naming Halle
denzel's great sound get hired okay safe
house is it safe maybe the safe house
what's the plot safe house is riding
around yeah yeah I think that's it John
Q it's not John Q I think it safe house
is it I think you're thinking of
Remember the Titans no no you sure do
you think I'd be safe house I can look
him no Pelican brief with Julie Roberts
no into the net for Julie Roberts that
he's not even in but you might be right
yeah it's been net but when that it's
the net we figured it out Julia Roberts
digging it up
all right we're we're a very movie
knowledgeable channel if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects become a reject I love it
when youtubers name their fans
oh yeah Jason Horton become a Horton
don't go that's the word are you
neighbor for now don't have any fans to
name them so yeah you do yourself become
a [ __ ] t/o
40 horror Horton how many horton hears a
who jokes did you get girl after
I got probably like 15 we're in Zurich
and that we sketch comedian you over
this weird thing sketch comedian white
guy white guy a little Jew in there yeah
a lot of you important here's a Jew yep
to get that yet what I don't get that as
much coordinators did you yeah
I know there's some anti-semites out
there like I don't care that's primarily
this is mister talking about religion
yeah you're welcome on my Jim